the Joe Rogan experience what is taking
out the Great Barrier Reef it's uh we're
heating the planet we're heating the
water it's a it's it's bleachy so
there's a couple things there's multiple
insults you have runoff from fertilizer
and pesticides from agriculture you have
the heating of the water these these
events when I say it it's dying it's
dying it's not like oh it's gonna come
back once once the coral is dead that's
it it's it's not gonna come back
sunscreen play a part in that as well
it's probably not there it's pretty it's
fairly remote like over in Hawaii it
would or there was a Caribbean but it's
pretty remote you have to get out
several miles to at the Great Barrier
Reef and it's if the further north you
go the more isolated it is we went the
entire length of the Great Barrier Reef
and it didn't look it got slightly
better as you got north but there's only
a couple boats there it's not like you
have you know thousands and hundreds of
thousands of tourists out and they bound
the beach you know the other thing is
acidification the burning of fossil
fuels is this acidifying the oceans is
now about thirty percent more acidic
than it was you know fifty years ago and
when do you make you know there's more
carbonic acid in the water it makes it
harder for the the corals to survive and
it's basically at these multiple insults
going on at the same time it's probably
not just one thing but there was a
massive bleaching about two years in a
row no Great Barrier Reef and so it's
it's disappearing in our lifetime that's
you know but if you look at we have a we
have a the last coral berry reef in
America is down in Florida and they have
like semi treated sewage coming out of
these off Falls that Lake if you swim
through these you know I've been out
there you know on these beaches you
could literally talk to somebody on the
beach or scream to him on the beach and
they have this green water coming out of
sewer pipes 200 meters away 300 meters
away and so they're dumping you know
semi treated sewage on the last reef in
America this is going on all around the
world and you know what we do I don't
know but we this is the last generation
that we have that can actually do
something about it because we're seeing
it disappear in our watch
and that's what I'm trying to do is try
to not just create the awareness that
something's going on that we have to do
something but try to create action
now when you say semi treated sewage
what do you mean by that well that's
that's what they reported so it's it it
smells like sewage it smells like crap
but if you if you go to the website it
says it's just semi treated I don't know
they they're not you know putting it
through the aerators they're not going
through the whole system but it smells
like [ __ ] to me you know you come out of
the water and it's like you know we all
stink you said now I said you know this
is this is at the but by the way this is
not the Hollywood Fort Lauderdale border
this is not like legal I mean this is
not a third-world country like how is
the United States allowing them to pump
semi treated sewage it's a very good
question you know there's there's so
many things to work on I know yet the
activists down there working on the
certs are trying to get people to see it
to know that this is going on and if you
know I think they close the beaches down
when you know when the wind shifts and
it starts to push it on shore of it if
you saw if you were on the beach and you
saw what was going on there you wouldn't
be sending your kids Sarah you want to
be going to Florida if you knew what was
going on on that beach we can make
arguments about whether or not you
should go to Florida all day long and
I'm with you a hundred percent but I
just can't imagine that they would allow
this and that I mean how much more would
it cost to treat it versus semi treated
how much more would it cost I don't have
an answer not do what they're doing so
good questions insane and then they that
they close the beach when the when the
water shifts and the wind shifts and
heads towards the shore and people get
sick and they probably don't even know
is Christ yeah I mean you know we'd be
out that when we're out one out fall day
that's what the Coleman outfall is
basically a sewer pipe you know
nothing's happening and all of a sudden
you start to hear this Rumble and then
you see this green Oh God and it's and
we're not talking like a little drain
pipe to like literally you could swim
through it not standing it that it's big
like four feet five feet tall now why I
mean why are they allowing I mean does
anybody have an argument for why that's
money money matters cost cuz less it
might cost money to treat sewage Jesus
Christ though that's insane
well there's a lot of things like that
but it seems like someone someone should
be held accountable for that like
whatever it caught cost-benefit that
they've decided is worth polluting the
ocean by pumping sewage into it well you
know it's a good question when we did -
now that I recall this is like five
years ago we tried to get an interview
with the key people down there but try
to like if you if you're gonna talk to
somebody about this nobody wants to go
on record to talk about it because it's
because it's really bad for tourism it's
you know and it's not good for the
political your video of it can we show
video well this is yeah I need to see
racer it's and racing extinction oh look
at that
there we go oh that's so disgusting four
months ago maybe Wow Wow
it is just a gigantic pipe pumping green
[ __ ] into the ocean why is it green by
the way Wow sure it'll be the color
under the water - you said it was a
green when you saw it as well right yeah
um yeah yeah well treated as it's
treated much better that way
well everything everything everything in
the spectrum there's a little bit of
blue or green look really food coloring
look at that
that's [ __ ] what is that fish fish
sandwich they can they can eat eat crap
oh Christ
yeah and build theirs then the fisherman
fish on a - oh Jesus Christ to catch
fish that are eating [ __ ] look at that
that is insane well looking at this pipe
and it looks like like a cloud of poison
is is being jettisoned out of this pipe
and into the ocean and then the
important part is if you came up you
would see people on the beach oh god I
mean and we're not talking about like
you know miles out at sea we're talking
about how in America I mean I know
Florida's barely America but how in
America is that possible it's a it's a
really good question we tried it you
know we try to explore some of these
issues but trying to get somebody to
talk on the record about this is really
difficult is there any other part of the
country
that has something like that not that I
know [ __ ] Florida Jesus Christ I mean
of course it's Florida I mean it is
there a place that it's so worthy of all
the stereotypes like Florida is it seems
like every time you think you've had
enough look at all these fish just
swimmin in the [ __ ] that surface looks
like it's boiling when all over come oh
god [ __ ] boiled a [ __ ] boil in Florida
and look at the ground it's all just
covered with algae well that's kind of a
point like what I'm saying is like you
know we always think somebody else
should be doing something about this and
you know that's why we do films is not
just to create the awareness and you
know to try to get something done about
it
[Applause]